so we've started to talk about
existentialism from the perspective of
the individual but it's necessary to
also understand the individual in
relationship to the whole and when
you're speaking about existential
personality theory it's even more
important to place the individual in a
broader context and the reason for that
at least in part is because it's while
it's for two reasons is it's that the
initial existential theorists most
particularly Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
were very interested in the political
consequences of inauthenticity
now Nietzsche believed that it was the
drive for truth that had been hyper
developed in Europe at least from a
technical perspective by Europeans
submission to Catholicism for for
thousands of years that eventually
overthrew Christianity in them in its
dogmatic form but he also believed that
the consequences of that would be the
weakening of the individual human being
at least initially who was then more or
less cast adrift but even more
importantly that there would be dire
political consequences and he was
particularly concerned about the
potential for collective collectivist
thinking to exert a murderous hold over
the modern world now interestingly at
exactly the same time it's so remarkable
how much Nietzsche's life in
Dostoyevsky's life paralleled one
another it's really as if they were two
sides of the same person because
Nietzsche was philosophizing more or
less explicitly well das Neves
he was exploring exactly the same themes
in his writing and there's multiple
forms of this parallelism so for example
when Nietzsche was the ideas that
Nietzsche was working out and beyond
good and evil were the same ideas that
possessed in many ways that possessed
Dostoyevsky's character Raskolnikov in
crime and punishment which is a pretty
nice parallel title to beyond good and
evil and then even more interestingly
Dostoevsky wrote a novel called the
possessed or The Devil's which I think
is the least accessible of his great
novels it takes about you know
Dostoyevsky's great novels are very long
like great Russian novels tend to be and
they have a very large cast of
characters and all of the characters
have three names
plus they have nicknames and so it's
quite difficult to keep track of them
and it takes quite a long time I think
for a modern reader especially one who's
not familiar with with with Russia or
Russian literature to to have it all
come together in a coherent narrative
hole and that's most pronounced I think
in his book the devil's but the devil's
is an unbelievably interesting book
because it describes individual
psychopathology and in some ways the
same way that Dostoevsky does in notes
from underground but it links it to this
susceptibility to a certain kind of
political extremism and utopianism in a
very direct way and so it notes for
underground for example the main
character is very psychologically weak
partly because he doesn't believe in
anything and so because he doesn't
believe in anything even if he's
offended even if he finds something
unacceptable personally he finds it very
difficult to stand up in a in opposition
to it or even to stand up for himself
because
he's so full of doubt that he questions
everything he he does and Dostoyevsky
presents the main character in notes
from underground as someone who's
fragmented to the point of radical
uncertainty now his characters in the
devil's have the same underlying problem
which is in some sense the demolition of
the integrity of their personalities by
the collapse of their formal individual
and collective belief systems but
instead of becoming riven by uncertainty
uncertainty and doubt they become
possessed by certainty and hence the
name the Devils or the possessed I
mentioned to you at one point that Jung
famously claimed that people didn't have
ideas that ideas had people which i
think is one of the loveliest lines I've
ever come across it's it's it's so
brilliant but Dostoyevsky's novel the
possessed is about how ideas have people
and his main character in that novel if
I recollect properly is named stavrogin
and stavrogin is the kind of nihilistic
thinker who turns to totalitarianism and
basically what happens in the Devils is
that he turns to precisely the ideas
that also manifested themselves in
radical Marxism and then later because
the possessed was written quite a bit
before the death of the czar in the
Russian Revolution
you know it's several decades before
that but Dostoevsky felt that these
ideas were in the air in some sense as
an alternative to classical European
thought including not only classical or
religious thought but also classical
enlightenment thought now Tolstoy wrote
a book called confessions which I would
very much recommend reading it's a very
short book and in confessions what
happens to Tolstoy is he talks about his
experience in Russia when the news of
the death of God in some sense swept
across Russia in a in us
a sudden storm the Russians had been
feudal for a very long period of time
and they were backwards in many ways
compared to the rest of Europe and they
had stuck in their medieval cultural
form far longer than most European
states but when that collapsed it
collapsed with amazing sudden with with
amazing instant 1080 and Tolstoy writes
in the confessions about remembering
when the idea first dawned on him and
many other people simultaneously that
the entire edifice of Orthodox
Christianity was no longer tenable and
then what happens with Tolstoy in
confession is that he describes his
absolute collapse as a integrated
psychological being and his descent into
the underworld roughly speaking
Tolstoy at the height of his success and
he was the most successful author in the
world at one point certainly and perhaps
you know people still argue that maybe
he was the greatest author who ever
lived although I think Dostoyevsky
deserves that title but I'm more of a
psychologist and a sociologist and
Tolstoy was a sociologist Tolstoy was
unwilling to wander around his estates
with either a gun or with a rope nearby
because he was afraid that he would
either shoot or hang himself and it's
because he despite his fame and his
great estates and his political his
political work he was very interested in
the emancipation of the serfs for
example he concluded in some sense that
life was an evil joke it was as if life
was an evil joke being played on mankind
by a cruel creator and that everything
was ultimately meaningless but finitely
terrible and and and generating nothing
but pointless suffering and Tolstoy said
very very clearly that a a man with
conviction who came to that conclusion
could only continue to live by deluding
himself and he thought in such a thought
he couldn't think himself out of the
proper
that his unwillingness to kill himself
was a form of cowardice once he had come
to that realization and so confession is
about that and you know he tries to turn
to the kind of religion that
characterized the Russian peasantry
which would be you know in some sense an
ignorant immersion in beliefs that
intellect have superseded but of course
that wasn't available to him and at the
end of confession something happens to
Tolstoy to redeem him in a sense but all
it is is a dream and he dreams of this
he dreams that he's suspended over a
great abyss by a rope and as far down as
he can look there's nothing but empty
space but then he turns to look up and
he can see the same rope above him
stretching up into the sky as far as it
can reach and that's basically how the
book ends and you know the inference is
something like Tolstoy dream revealed to
him the proposition that although there
were abysmal depths beneath mankind so
to speak from a psychological
perspective that we were also supported
by something infinite but it's not
articulated like the whole book just
ends with the dream so well so
Dostoevsky lays out the underground
political movements that were
characteristic of late the late nineteen
or the late 1800s in Russia and he
describes the emergence of the type of
person who ends up after the Russian
Revolution after the first world war
becoming committed and involved in the
collectivization process in Russia and
it's virtually impossible to overstate
how terrible the collectivization
process was right from its onset you
know you'll still hear apologists for
Marxism and communism talk about the
fact that the Soviet Union was captured
by a cult of personality under Stalin
and that that's why the ethical
presuppositions of Marxism transformed
into political our
became so corrupted but I think that's
absolute nonsense and I think it's
nonsense of the most dangerous and
reprehensible type and I think that for
two reasons the first reason was Stalin
was unbelievably murderous thug he
pretty much killed everyone he knew
including almost all of the they called
them
what were they I don't remember the term
there were old revolutionaries all of
the Bolsheviks who ran the revolution
who didn't die during the revolution or
of natural causes afterwards they were
all killed by Stalin he probably killed
his wife he killed pretty much everybody
he knew I mean he was and he was a like
an underground operative for Lenin
during the revolution itself where he
learned to be committed from an
ideological perspective he'd come from
quite an intensely religious background
committed from an ideological
perspective but then basically asked
acting as a guerrilla assassin during
the revolution itself and then later he
rose to power it he certainly used
Lenin's political machinations as
machinations as a as a template for his
later activity but Lenin was no
when it came to extraordinarily brutal
activity motivated by utopian dreams now
what seemed to happen in some sense is
that you can imagine and we're looking
at the political structure the political
movements of whole Nations we're going
down to the bottom to look at it from a
psychological perspective instead of
thinking it of it from an economic
perspective or a power perspective in
some sense it's a it's a Jungian
analysis of the rise of political
movements in in Europe and across the
world with an existential spin you can
imagine that what classical Christianity
had set up for people was not only a
belief in in a shared moral reality that
that everyone was super
to be participating in but also some
meaning for for some meaning for each
individual's life to some degree no
matter how much they were suffering and
then the promise of a kind of perfection
after death and of course people like
Freud and people like Marx considered
that an illusion designed either to
protect the population from fear of
death
so that would be Freud's argument or
Marx's argument would be well that that
was a conspiracy in some sense promoted
by the political and religious elite to
keep the people who are being oppressed
in their place well of course there's
some truth to both of those but there's
a difference between some truth and that
truth and any extraordinarily complex
phenomena has multiple causal elements
and those are two important ones because
of course anxiety about death and power
are two very important psychological
phenomena and they play their role in
determining any important collective or
individual activity but you can't forget
about the rest of the the rest of the
story now so this collapses and that
leaves a void and that void is a void in
people's souls so to speak it makes them
nihilistic for example because they
don't have any they can't see any
ultimate meaning in what they're doing
but it also simultaneously makes them
more susceptible to utopian mass
movements of a rational type and of
course that's exactly what happened with
regards to the Marxists and with regards
to the fascist so what Hitler offered
his followers in collaboration with them
because it wasn't so much that Hitler
told people what he wanted them to think
as it was that Hitler listened to what
the crowds wanted and then told it back
to them in a collaboration that extended
across his entire rule because Hitler
was a great populist and he was very
very good at receiving messages from the
audience
but Hitler basically offered his
population the dream of racial
superiority and world domination you
know as well as many many other things
that went along with that so and then of
course Marx offered his followers the
idea that the oppressed could shed their
chains and that everyone could unite
workers that intellectuals alike in
particular it was them it was more the
the owning the owning class the
bourgeois as they're still called by
some people who were the the evil
oppressors and the union of worker and
intellectual would eventually Shepherd
in a golden age where everyone offered
to society as much as they could offer
and took from society as much as they
needed right and that's the famous
phrase from each according to his
ability to each according to his need
which sounds wonderful you can I can
understand why that would be an
attractive slogan but if you start to
think about how that would be
administered in practice and you really
start to think it through you realize
very very rapidly that it's a rep as a
recipe for absolute disaster
partly because well how do you tell the
difference between your need in your
need if your mother needs cancer surgery
and your genius brother needs to do go
do his PhD whose need Trump's well and
that's just a trivial problem because
all of you have those competing needs
and how anybody is ever going to
adjudicate between the value of needs is
beyond cognitive comprehension it just
can't be done not without brutality
especially because you know there's
limited resources and then the next
question is well okay you're supposed to
contribute according to your ability
how much ability do you have you know
what that meant in practice that was
that people were frequently worked to
death because the ability isn't a
definable entity you know and unless you
have some sort of complicated and
functional system to negotiate to allow
people to negotiate amongst themselves
peaceably about what they're going to
offer and what they're going to take you
have to turn it over to something like a
centralized Authority and you know
that's just well you don't need much
imagination to understand that that
would be an absolute catastrophe and it
was an absolute catastrophe
now one of the things that's really
interesting about Dostoyevsky's book The
Devil's is that it's segways almost
perfectly into Alexander Solzhenitsyn
scription of the emergence of the
Russian prisoners the Soviet prison
camps after the Revolution so basically
what happened and this is what
Solzhenitsyn revealed in the 1970s was
that because the communist system was so
financially untenable the principles
just didn't work for all sorts of
reasons the the system ended up running
basically on a system of work camps and
so much of what the Russians produced
the Soviets produced which wasn't very
much by the way although they got
industrialized very very rapidly was
produced by people who were basically
enslaved and that's the only way the
system could continue to function now
Solzhenitsyn estimated that between
nineteen and 1919 which is basically the
end of the first world war and 1959
which is basically when the Stalinist
era came to an end so that's only 40
years that 60 million people were killed
in the Soviet Union as a consequence of
internal repression I didn't count the
Second World War
now people debate these figures and
Solzhenitsyn is surprisingly to me a
controversial figure because I don't see
where the controversy is people complain
about his numbers claiming that death
count of 60 million people over that
period of time is mathematically
untenable but reason more reasonable
estimates if you want to put it that way
put it up to 20 or 30 million and though
the truth of the matter is that no one
knows and that even makes it worse I
mean we do know for example that that's
the attempts at collectivization in the
1920s led to the creation of a
agricultural catastrophe made worse by
Stalin's peculiar
economic policies that killed six
million people in the in the Ukraine in
the 1930s now how many of you knew that
how many of you know about the Ukrainian
famine how many didn't know okay one
thing you might want to ask yourself is
why the hell don't you know you know you
know lots of things about the mass
deaths in the in the 20th century but my
experience has been that students in the
West know almost nothing about what
happened as a consequence of the
imposition of radical left-wing
dictatorships and it's not trivial
thirty million in the Soviet Union let's
say six million in Cambodia under Paul
Pott Paul Pott was trained at the
Sorbonne and he took what he learned at
the Sorbonne from his radical left-wing
professors and put it into practice in
Cambodia emptied out the cities because
he had learned that under standard
Marxist Dogma city people who are mostly
bourgeois were parasites on the workers
he emptied the cities and killed six
million people and then in China during
Mao's Cultural Revolution while no one
really knows Seoul Jeunesse
Solzhenitsyn's estimates were a hundred
million but you can take half that if
you want these are massive massive
numbers of people and part of the reason
that I think it's reprehensible to pin
the absolute catastrophes of the Soviet
state on the Stalinist cult of
personality was that it didn't only
happen in the Soviet Union it happened
with with catastrophic results in all
sorts of places where these economic
policies were implemented and I believe
that the reason that Western students
roughly speaking don't know about these
things is that the the the
intelligentsia of the West Europe and
North America we're going to say for the
time being
were so heavily influenced by radical
left-wing ideas from the 1920s well to
the present day that these facts have
never been made as have never been
disseminated in his thorough a manner as
is only appropriate so the French
intellectuals for example from whom
post-modernism derived people like
jean-paul Sartre and Foucault and a very
large group of French intellectuals who
were involved in the student radical
left student movements in the late 1960s
and who ended up barricading the streets
of Paris in 1968 which is when the
student movement sort of peaked and then
and then fell away um
they never apologized in any real sense
for their the fact of being enamored of
well at least in part the policies of
Stalin and also the policies of Mao and
there's no excuse for that
so now the problem is of course is that
left-wing radical left-wing political
and economic ideas are intellectually
quite coherent like they make sense once
you accept a certain set of axioms like
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need you accept
that axiom you accept the idea that the
the capital class the capitalist class
which is roughly anyone who owns
anything only owns what they own because
they've stolen it from someone else so
that there's labor is productive but
nothing else is productive everything
else is a secondary derivation of labor
and you know that's an absolutely
moronic economic theory because
obviously there's work that has value
there's work that has no value the fact
that it's difficult has almost no
relationship to whether or not it has
value unfortunately you know it's not
like the political system or the
economic system is a perfect mirror of
effort it's not like that at all so
you might say that
well I would say really what happened in
the 20th century is once people stopped
worshipping and externalize deity they
started to worship if they were
intelligent they started to worship
rational utopian ideas and if they
weren't as intelligent they turned to
the state like identification with the
state like the Nazis for example
identification with the state as an
alternative source of collective power
and both of those were in
comprehensively devastating and we're
not done with it yet
you know I mean one of the things that
happened in the Soviet Union and
Solzhenitsyn one of who's I have you
read one of his the chapters of The
Gulag Archipelago which is an amazing
piece of writing one of the things that
Solzhenitsyn Solzhenitsyn points out is
there was this extensive prison camp
system in the Soviet Union that he
called the gulag archipelago it was this
chain of camps all across the Soviet
Union and if you were thrown in there
because you were a political prisoner
you were the worst kind of prisoner and
you could be thrown in there as a
political prisoner pretty much for
expressing any opinion whatsoever about
the state which is we're going to get
back to that as we tie this together
with existentialism now the Communists
we regarded the murderers and the
rapists and the thieves as socially
friendly elements because it was a it
was part of Marxist doctrine that the
only reason that you would become a
murderer or a thief or a rapist was
because you were part of an oppressed
class and your poverty was what
generated your crime so in some sense
you couldn't be held personally
responsible for it an upshot of that was
that the thieves and the rapists and the
murderers ran the prisons well Russia
right now is a mafia state there's
evidence for example that Putin is the
richest man in the world and he has
almost singular power over this over the
affairs of the Soviet Union the former
Soviet Union
the Russians the Soviets killed anybody
that had any capacity for independent
thought and they raised the thugs to to
the highest positions of authority and
you guys are going to be dealing with
that for the rest of your life so and if
you think that that's changed you're
wrong
it hasn't changed at all Russia's just
transformed from a totalitarian
communist state into a mafia state and
that's a big problem so we're not done
with this yet and one of the things that
Solzhenitsyn he was this is why I use
him as a psychological thinker you know
people generally consider Viktor Frankl
that the primary existential
psychologist or psychiatrist now Viktor
Frankl came through the Nazi prison
camps and he developed logotherapy as a
consequence of that and logotherapy
what part of the principles of
logotherapy were laid forth in his book
man's search for meaning and one of
Frankel's propositions was essentially
that because life is suffering and can
be unbearable suffering that it's
necessary for people to have a
countervailing meaning to buttress
themselves against the tragedy of
existence and Frankel basically claimed
and this is an existential claim that if
you that you could find that meaning and
collective belief but that there were
terrible dangers associated with that
and so your moral obligation was to find
that meaning within the confines of your
own authentic individual life and you
can see that sort of idea also arising
in the thought of Carl Rogers for
example and it's also there in Jung
because of course Jung believed that
there was this path he called
individuation which was the flowering
and manifestation of the healthy and
integrated the deep healthy and
integrated fundamental human personality
of course Piaget believed something
similar although more collective because
for Piaget
the hammering of your psyche into
something resembling an integrated state
also had to be done in active concert
with all of the people around you you
know because you were organizing
yourself into a coherent internal game
where all your little sub personalities
could find their place well
simultaneously doing that with other
people over long spans of time but you
can see this the theme there's a theme
that emerges in all of those thinkers
and one of the themes is this that there
are healthy pathways to psychological
development and the existentialists in
particular although this was also the
case with young young worked as a secret
agent for the American government and
provided the President of the United
States with psychological reports on
Hitler's state of mind I wasn't even
discovered until about three years ago
so all of these thinkers were concerned
about collective pathology and at the
same time concerned about individual
development and I don't think you can
really separate those things and the
reason that I use Solzhenitsyn is
because he basically takes the same tack
as Viktor Frankl especially in the gulag
archipelago but it's a much more
thoroughly developed body of thought
like I'm an admirer of Frankel I think
man's search for meaning is an amazing
book but it's a good book whereas the
Gulag Archipelago is a devastatingly
profound book they're not in the same
they're not in the same league you know
it's it's like Solzhenitsyn is - Viktor
Frankl what Dostoevsky is - virtually
any other author you know there's this I
don't know what it is about the damn
Russians maybe their suffering has done
something to them over the hundreds of
years that it's been in place but they
can produce people of unbelievable
profundity as well as you know crooks
who are crooked and and had murderous
beyond comprehension so you know
Solzhenitsyn was very interested in
trying to understand what happened to
the Soviet Union was how that it could
how could it transform itself into a
state that
powered the majority or a vast minority
of its citizens and often the best of
the citizenry I mean it was very common
in the Soviet Union and this is through
the entire Soviet bloc I mean you were
required to be an informer roughly
speaking you were certainly taught to be
an informer at school and you know the
Soviets made much of children who were
patriotic enough to turn in their own
parents you know they were held up as
models of behavior and it was very
frequently the case that if you denounce
the neighbor that was a really good
waste way for your family to get their
apartment and of course apartments were
an incredibly scarce supply and far too
many people generally lived in the same
locale and so if you were a
three-generation family living in a
one-bedroom apartment one of the most
effective ways to get your children a
new apartment was to denounce the
neighbor down the hallway and as a
reward you'd be given the apartment well
you can imagine who would take advantage
of that kind of offer now what happened
in the 1920s during the collectivization
so here it here's the idea how the serfs
had been emancipated in the late 1800s
and they were basically feudal
inhabitants of parcels of land who were
more or less owned by the nobility it
wasn't exactly slavery but because the
serfs had certain sets of rights but it
was it was culture to slavery then to
anything else that you would
conceptualize from a modern perspective
the serfs were emancipated in the late
1800s actually at about the same time
that slavery was abolished in the United
States approximately the same period of
time anyways and so there was and of
course Russia had a very rich
aristocracy and it had a monarchy and so
the idea that and then it went through
the First World War and was viciously
demolished during the first world war
the idea that there was an underclass of
impoverished people and an over class of
aristocratic parasites was a compelling
idea and it was a compelling idea in
many places other than Russia especially
at the turn of the century and
that was partly because the Industrial
Revolution was brutal and farm life was
very difficult and there was a massive
gap between rich and poor and you know
that was that was an attractive
political explanation and it had partial
truth because of course people are
exploited and often poor people are poor
because they're exploited but there's
lots of other reasons to be poor and
rich people are sometimes rich because
they exploit but of course there's lots
of other reasons to be rich as well so
these ideas were put into practice by
the Bolshevik revolutionaries and one of
the most one of the most comprehensive
manifestations of that idea took place
in the 1920s when the Soviets underwent
a process that they called
dekulakization now so imagine this so in
the in the late 1800s the serfs were
emancipated what that meant was that
some people started to own their own
land you know they weren't Nobles that
owned it owned the states they were more
like what we would consider sort of
middle-class farmers so they owned some
land they owned some animals they might
own a half-decent house in the town and
they might have done enough or been
fortunate enough to have collected
enough money and enough property and
enough stability so that they could hire
one or two people to help them with
their crops so they were by no means
rich but they were they were the
successful farming class of the Soviet
Union
okay now the Communists put forward the
idea that there was no way that you
could have a brick house in town and
owned more cows than your neighbor and
have some productive land put aside and
worst of all hire someone to work for
you unless you had essentially stolen
that from your neighbors so then the
Communists would send out activists from
the cities and they would go to these
towns and start spreading this doctrine
okay now you've got to think this
through now
who is going to be most responsive to
that doctrine well it's going to be the
most jealous
useless jealous and resentful people in
town it's going to be the guys that are
hanging around in the local bar drinking
themselves half to death every day who
feel that they've been totally screwed
over by life that are that hate the
people who have come up with a modicum
of prosperity and then someone comes
along and says hey as far as our
doctrine goes those people you hate
they're nothing better than thieves it's
your moral and patriotic duty to rise up
and take everything they have and that's
exactly what happened so during the
dekulakization process there basically
be mobs of jealous and resentful thugs
who would go into the houses of these
moderately prosperous people who were
actually the only people in the soviet
union who knew how to farm and they took
everything everything they go into their
houses and stripped them bare and take
all the animals and and then what the
Communists did with the kulaks was they
allowed them to take they were going to
resettle them up mostly in Siberia well
there was no settlements in Siberia so
basically what they meant what that
meant was hastily built rail lines would
take them in in the middle of the winter
with their families and dump them on the
frozen Prairie where well all the
children would die and everybody more or
less would freeze to death and so you
know the Communists said while you could
take two months worth of food with you
but of course they didn't make any
provisions for having that two months of
food and after you had gone through the
process of decolonisation you could
bloody well be sure that you didn't have
two months of food left that you could
take when you were suddenly bundled onto
the trains and driven to the middle of
nowhere well you know after a number of
years of that which which also involved
the forced collectivization of all the
remaining people the distribution of the
land in principle to everyone and then
collective farming while the entire
agricultural economy fell apart and that
particularly the case in the Ukraine
which is a very very fertile part of the
world and which was the breadbasket of
Russia roughly speaking
well everybody starved the Communists
had to put up posters telling people
that eating their children was wrong
they would kill people if they went out
in the fields after the harvest so
they'd go out with her big harvesting
machines vacuum up all the grain ship it
to the cities because the cities were
also starving and leave nothing for the
people behind and then if you went out
there in the field like if you were a
mother and your child was starving to
death and you went out there in the
field and you picked up individual
kernels of grains so that you gather
them in a cup and bring them home to
feed their fat your family that was an
executable crime because you were
suppose you're stealing from the state
if you were going to go out there and
bloody well pick up the wretched little
kernels that are left you know calf
crushed into the ground that it was your
moral obligation to turn those over to
the state because I suppose that was
part of your ability and the need
somewhere else was greater
well Solzhenitsyn was very interested in
how the hell this sort of thing could
even happen
you know because and he wasn't
interested in it precisely from a
political perspective I mean I would say
he started being interested in it from a
political perspective analyzing the
actions of people like Lenin and Stalin
he wrote a very interesting book on
Lenin which was one of the first
documents that made Lenin out to be the
same sort of person that Stalin was even
though I think now the historical
evidence for that is crystal clear but
it soldier Nansen ended up more by doing
a psychological analysis and that's
because as he considered what had
happened to his country he couldn't
escape the proposition that the reason
it had become so corrupt was because all
of the individuals within it had allowed
themselves to become corrupt and so one
if you're wondering for example how you
know your political system has become
corrupt or or let's let's put it
differently how you know that any system
that you happen to be embedded in has
become corrupt one way of
of assessing that judging that is to
determine for yourself whether or not
you're allowed to say what you think you
know I mean you can genuinely think
something without it being right
obviously but if you genuinely think
something that's your truth and you know
in the marketplace of free ideas
everyone is allowed to express their
truth that doesn't mean everyone's right
it doesn't mean that you have any right
to have people listen to you
it doesn't grant you any access to power
but at least you get to say what you
think and if that's withheld from you or
you're punished for it you can bloody
well be certain that the system has
started to take a vicious turn towards
oppression and repression and that the
outcome of that's going to be bad even
if your thoughts are reprehensible you
should be allowed to put them forward
not least because the rest of the
society needs to know where the
dangerous wingnuts are so that you can
so that the ideas can be brought up you
know out in the open and disqualified
you know so freedom of speech
encompasses the freedom to say the most
outrageous things just so everybody
knows what you're thinking because if
you can't say it that doesn't mean
you're not thinking it it's just going
to go underground and fester there like
a Freudian repressed thought so freedom
of speech has nothing to do with
protecting the kind of speech that is
necessarily pro-social it's exactly the
opposite of that is you want everybody
to say what they're thinking because
then you know what they're thinking and
it's and well and it's also often the
case that people can't come to the truth
unless they're allowed to express their
untruth and have that you know
criticized in the in public forums so
Solzhenitsyn's conclusion was that
there was no way that the terrors of the
Soviet state could have got the foothold
that they got unless individual people
were willing to falsify that nature of
their own experience and in the Gulag
Archipelago he basically did he
basically describes a society it's 2,700
pages long this book and it's little
tiny type it's a
very very comprehensive examination he
basically shows you story after story
tells you story after story of how
people falsified their experience in the
service of the state and so the story is
basically something like this he said
this is what happens when you give your
god-given soul over to human Dogma so
the basic idea is well you're left in it
you're left in a sphere that it is is as
the absence of a well-defined meaning so
that's a consequence of the collapse of
the previous belief systems and because
you're torn apart by that in some sense
you don't know where to turn in one
direction is of course nihilistic and
the other direction perhaps is
totalitarian now another direction might
be that you try to figure things out on
your own and still live a life that's
truthful and and and that has integrity
but we're going to leave that alone for
a moment because it's it's difficult to
even conceptualize that might exist if
you've already swallowed the
presupposition that all the values have
fallen apart you turn to totalitarianism
okay well it tells you what to think it
tells you how to act it tells you how
your society should be structured but it
does some things that are even more
subtle and subtly destructive than that
because what it also does is positive
future utopia which is an organization
of the state where everyone has
everything they want permanently now
Dostoyevsky when he wrote Snow --tz--
from underground he basically said well
this was way before the Communist
revolution he said he was talking about
these sorts of utopian egalitarian
communitarians he said they've got human
beings completely wrong right right from
the bottom up because if you took the
typical person he says you if you gave
them everything they possibly wanted to
eat so that all they had to ever do was
eat delicious cakes and they didn't have
any other responsibilities than What did
he say
indulging in the continuation of the
human species and so that if they were
so happy that if you put them under
water nothing but
people's of bliss would float up to the
surface the first thing that people who
were put in that situation would do
would be to wander around smashing
things just so that something unexpected
and interesting would happen you know
it's a brilliant critique of utopianism
because it's exactly right he said he
basically Dostoyevsky said people are so
crazy that they'd rather be subjected to
inconvenient and unexpected occurrences
than just to lay there all saw per if
acquit bliss and so that there was
something wrong with the whole utopia
notion right from the get-go because
that's just not what people are like
they'd rather have interesting trouble
than non interesting perfection you know
and I think that's an incredibly
powerful idea but anyways this you can
just think about that in relationship to
your own character I mean how often do
you do something that's trouble just to
see what happens I mean it's exactly
what people are like you know even
chimpanzees juvenile chimps if they see
an old male sleeping underneath the tree
they'll go and poke him with a stick
just to see what happens you know and
it's like well if you can't see human
Humanity in that sort of behavior
there's something wrong with you so but
the utopians offered this vision of the
future which was basically paradise on
earth but they also proposed that it was
something that could be attained through
certain types of you know direct
political action which usually meant
well fix your neighbor up or even worse
meant steal what he has because he
shouldn't have it anyways and the
problem with the utopian vision
essentially was that if my theory is
associated with the future utopia in a
logical way so I can make a case to you
that if you do this and we do that and
they do this and we organising things
this way then will usher in a period of
prosperity that's almost heavenly in its
in its promise the problem with that is
it means we can do any bloody thing
bloody thing we want right now because
the end product is so valuable that it
justifies it and so what happens is that
the utopian vision turns into a
rationale for the most destructive forms
of behavior in the here and now and then
when someone is called to task for
it's like what the hell do you think
you're doing you know they'll say
something like well you can't make an
omelet without breaking eggs you know
and that's all well and good if you
happen to be making the omelet but it's
not so damn good if you happen to be one
of the eggs and there were plenty of
eggs broken on the way to you know the
Soviet vision of success well and you
know there's good evidence Stalin by the
time the mid-1950s came around there's
pretty decent evidence from the KGB
archives that he was preparing to launch
a thermonuclear war against Europe I
mean he'd already killed god only knows
how many million people by that point a
few more hundred million weren't really
going to weigh that heavily on his
conscience the last book I read on
Stalin which was published which was
called Stalin it was written by a guy
who had access to the KGB and communist
party archives
he claimed that Khrushchev and three
other people killed Stalin in the late
1950s to stop him from invading Europe
so I mean you know in the battle between
the Communists utopians and the West we
came this close to wiping everything out
several times so now what happened in
some sense was this is that this theory
was laid out to cover the world so the
Marxist theory was presented itself as a
scientific theory an inevitable theory
of history and the theory of history was
that the warfare between the oppressed
and the oppressor was the primary fact
of life and that that needed to
transform itself into a egalitarian
utopia and that there were certain
states that political states that
mankind would have to go through to
reach that end ok so that was basically
the theory and part of the theory was
that in order to get to that point then
resources had to be distributed equally
to all which sounds fine in principle
but then again the devil is always in
the details and how to distribute
resources equally is by no means
self-evident you know part of the reason
that the English came up with the idea
of the free market this is
Smith fundamentally is because Smith
figured out that trying to figure out
what things were worth is so complicated
that you can't actually calculate it so
then we would say well what's your coat
worth I'd say well would you give me
your coat for five dollars $2 thousand
dollars okay so so but so the point
being is that you know there's no way of
establishing the worth of things because
the worth of one thing is it's worth in
relationship to all other things of
worth like it's a continual interaction
between all things of worth and the only
way you can make that calculation is by
letting people individual people make
micro choices and that the value of
things is established as a consequence
of a hundred billion micro choices we
call that in the modern world we call
something about some that's something
like distributed cognition you know it's
like you're outsourcing a price decision
to the marketplace what's this thing
worth well the answer is whatever people
will trade for it and it's not a cop-out
it's it's an illustration indication of
the fact that you can't come up with a
computation that will allow you to
determine what something is worth so I
mean I can give you an example of that
from my own life trying to figure out
what something is worth I developed some
software to help people hire employees
and we did the mathematical calculations
and figured out that if people use this
particular software instead of going
through a interview process which
doesn't work very well that it would
basically if they used if they gave it
to ten people to select one employee
that it would save them about thirty
five percent of the salary of the hired
person per year so if you hired someone
who was being paid a hundred thousand
dollars then the return on investment
would be thirty five thousand dollars a
year and we could sell this for say well
we didn't know what how much do you
charge for the tests then so you might
say well if it
$35,000 a year you're going to have this
person around for four years because
that's how long the average person stays
in their job that's a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and so then you only
have to use ten tests and so maybe we
could take half of the first year so
that would be $17,000 so it'd be
seventeen hundred and fifty dollars a
test and you'd get like a thirty what is
it you get a eight times return on your
investment well you should be just
jumping at that well it doesn't work
like that at all we ended up having to
sell it for about twenty dollars a test
and we could hardly sell it to anyone
because well for reasons that are far
too complex to go into but my point is
is that it's impossible to make a
pricing decision it's really really
difficult and to think that you could
make a conscious and pre-programmed
pricing decision for every single
commodity is completely insane and
that's what they tried to do in the
Soviet Union and I read at one point
that the central purse up right pricing
committee had to make ten thousand
pricing decisions a day well you can't
even come up with the price of one you
put things on Kijiji you know it's like
well what's it worth well you look at
what everyone else is paying for it
roughly speaking and then it depends on
how quickly you want to sell it what
kind of shape it's in and you know it's
complicated and you have a pricing
guideline you just have to look the damn
thing up it's still hard to figure out
what the price is but imagine you have
no comparative information at all
what's a hypodermic needle worth well I
guess it depends on whether you need it
to inject the penicillin that's going to
save your life or if you're just putting
it in your cupboard to store it but it's
a complicated decision alright so
anyways this utopian scheme was set up
and we're acting on the proposition that
people used it at least in part as a
replacement for their alternative for
their old belief systems which i think
is a perfectly reasonable proposition
but we're also going to take a
psychoanalytic approach and we're going
to say well it also allowed people to
manifest bad faith because if your worth
can be determined by how good a cog you
are in the fascist or communist
machinery it pretty much alleviates you
of any responsibility that you have to
have
for your own life so that for every
positive reason that you might join a
utopian movement there's a negative
reason which as well you can benefit
from its exploitive nature and you don't
have to take any responsibility
well Solzhenitsyn and Frankel both
talked about that a lot as did Nietzsche
but Frankel and Solzhenitsyn are more
interesting because they actually happen
to live through the imposition of
systems like that and could see them
from the inside
Soulja Vincent's first observation was
Marxist economics didn't work well that
was a big problem because it was
supposed to work and not only was it
supposed to work it was supposed to work
perfectly and what that basically meant
was that if it didn't work you only had
one of two options you could either
abandon the damn system and start to
complain about the fact that you had to
line up for bread for four hours a day
which was perfectly typical daily
activity for people for example in
Poland and in Russia before the wall
came down everything cost nothing but
there wasn't anything to buy so it
wasn't very much of a bargain and
instead of paying for your bread with
money you just paid for it with time you
stayed in line for two hours or three
hours or five hours and when you got to
the front of the line at the department
store you took whatever the hell was
there because you didn't even know what
it was that you were going to be buying
when you joined the line up and so it
wasn't like it was free you just paid
for it with your time
so Solzhenitsyn noted that what happened
as the system continued to manifest its
counterproductive properties was that
either people had the choice of saying
oh this isn't working worth a damn there
must be something rotten in Denmark or
pretending that everything was all right
and lying about everything and that's
what they did they lied about everything
and so we've got to you got the
situation up to the point where in East
Germany before the wall came down one
out of every three people was a
government informer that meant if you
had a family of six people two of them
were telling the government what you
were talking about at dinner and that
was their duty and so what that meant in
these societies was no one ever said
anything that they meant ever
and if they did the probability that the
KGB was going to kick down their door at
4:00 in the morning
and take them off to the Central Prison
before dumping them in some damn camp
where they'd never see anybody they ever
do for the rest of their life was
extraordinarily high so you watched
everything you said and everything you
thought around your wife around your
brother around your sister around your
children and the whole system ground
onward in a mire of absolute deception
and lie and Solzhenitsyn's point as well
and this is one of Frankel's main points
is that if people had had if people had
decided to stop lying the system would
have ground to a halt but that isn't
what people did they just kept lying now
he noticed when he was in the prison
camps because he was in them for a long
time he did encounter people inside the
camps like Frankel did who were
absolutely unwilling to falsify their
experience so for example one of the
things that had to happen if you were
arrested by the KGB and sentenced to a
prison camp was that it was necessary
for you to sign a confession and that's
so peculiar you think huh they're going
to arrest you arbitrarily and put you on
trial for trumped-up nonsense
why couldn't they just Forge your damn
signature it's like why did they care if
you confessed and the answer to that was
well it was part of the way the system
kept itself validated because the people
who were torturing you could justify the
torture if you agreed that you were
actually at fault and so rather than
face the fact that they were just doing
something corrupt innocent people they'd
extract a confession out of you so that
they could convince themselves that you
deserved exactly what you got now
Solzhenitsyn said at one time that one
person who stopped lying to bring down a
tyranny now that's a pretty radical
statement but you know when he wrote the
Gulag Archipelago I mean he memorized
that damn book when he was in one of the
prison camps because they didn't give
him pencil or paper and even if they did
they wouldn't been able to carry the
damn manuscript around so he basically
memorized it 2700 pages you know written
at the volume of a very loud screen
when he got out of the prison camps he
had two copies of it typed up one by one
typist and one by another they didn't
know each other the KGB broke into the
one typists home and stole the
manuscript and she killed herself
then the guellen you can understand why
you know what she thought this was a
tremendously valuable piece of work and
she thought it was the only copy and
they destroyed it well he couldn't even
tell her that there was another one
because they would have got it too
well then it was exported to the West in
unpublished form and published in
English to begin with and it was an
absolute bombshell like and it was
published in 1974 was at that point
anyone who had any moral integrity
whatsoever and who was also literate
read that and said oh okay game over all
those propositions they're wrong beyond
belief and that part of what we thought
might be possible is done well you know
that happened to some degree it
communism lost a tremendous amount of
its intellectual credibility and that
was part of the reason that it fell over
in 1989 but you know it's not like
everybody has shaken their no it's not
as if everyone's faith and that sort of
thing is being shaken you know there's
this massive stream of Marxist
utopianism that's still running through
post-modernism and that's that's you
know made its way to Western
universities all over the world so
despite all of this despite these tens
of millions of deaths and this total
moral corruption and no one even knows
about it and I don't understand that
it's completely it's completely
unacceptable
it's the biggest lesson of the 20th
century you know and we hear a lot about
the Holocaust and no wonder it was a
truly terrible thing but there's all
these other events of the 20th century
that we're absolutely catastrophic and
they're not part of general knowledge
and you have to ask yourself why because
if we can't learn from that if we can't
learn from all those tens of millions of
people who were tortured to death and
and and and ruined in political prisons
like you got to ask yourself can we
actually learn any
thing I'm going to read you some of the
things that Solzhenitsyn wrote he
doesn't say the name of this person it's
in it's in dashes someone he meant he
met either in a camp or afterwards he
told our executions were carried out at
a dock a camp on the Peshawar River they
would take the opposition members with
their things out of the camp compound on
a prisoner transport at night and
outside the compound stood the small
house of the third section these were
people who were opposing the communist
ideology the condemned men were taken
into a room one at a time and there the
camp guard sprang on them their mouths
were stuffed with something soft and
their arms were bound with cords behind
their backs then they were led out into
the courtyard where harnessed carts were
waiting the bound prisoners were piled
on the carts five to seven at a time and
driven off to the Gorka the camp
cemetery on arrival they were tipped
into big pits that had already been
prepared and buried alive not out of
brutality no it had been calculated than
when dragging and lifting them it was
much easier and more efficient to cope
with living people than with corpses the
work went on for many nights at a dock
and that is how the moral political
unity of our party was achieved this is
from Franco this is the concentration
camps in Nazi Germany these those were
the size of cities by the way I mean
when you think of camp I don't know what
image it brings up in your mind but you
know you might think of an enclosure the
size of a city block or something like
that but that's not right these places
were the size of cities because there
was tens of thousands of people in them
the most ghastly moment of the 24 hours
of camp life was the awakening when at a
still nocturnal hour the three shrill
blows of a whistle tourists pitilessly
from her exhausted sleep and from the
longings in our dreams we then began the
tussle with our wet shoes into which we
could scarcely force our feet which
sore and swollen with edema and there
were the usual moans and groans about
petty troubles such as the snapping of
wires which replaced shoelaces one
morning I heard someone whom I knew to
be brave and dignified cry like a child
because he finally had to go to the
snowy marching grounds in his bare feet
as his shoes were too shrunken for him
to wear in these ghastly moments I found
a little bit of comfort a small piece of
bread which I drilled my pocket and
munched with absorbed delight
this is Solzhenitsyn so in these camps
people were set out to work and it would
depend on where they were what they were
working on but maybe it was the digging
of a canal or maybe they were setting up
a factory or or they were doing
something that required the generally
required intense physical effort and
each of these camps had a they had a
goal right that was established from
above it's like a 5-year plan your camp
is to produce this much in this period
of time and then if you didn't produce
that much in that period of time then
the people who ran the camp were going
to be held accountable which generally
meant that they were going to be put in
some camp themselves and so there was
every reason to drive people to their
death in order to fulfill the work norms
and when that didn't happen they just
falsified the records anyways because
what the hell was their choice and
Solzhenitsyn talks about how they got
around the rules in cold lower than
sixty degrees below zero work days were
written off in other words on such days
the records showed that the workers have
not gone out to work well so then you
can tell a bit about the benevolence of
the Soviet state if it was 55 below well
then you could go out to work but if it
was 60 below you got to stay home while
that isn't even how it worked in other
words on 60-below days the record showed
that the workers had not gone to work
but they chased them out anyways and
whatever they squeezed out of them on
those days was added to the other days
thereby raising the percentages and the
servile medical section wrote off those
who froze to death on such cold days on
some other basis and the ones who were
left who could no longer walk
we're straining every sinew to crawl
along an all-fours on the way back to
camp
the convoy simply shot so that they
wouldn't escape before they could come
back to get them so Stalin had a group
of people hundreds of thousands of
people dig a canal in the 1930s and
unfortunately I can't remember the name
of the canal but some three hundred
thousand people froze to death digging
it with spades and shovels in the middle
of the Russian winter and when it was
finished it was so shallow that none of
the ships that were planned to go up and
down it could use it but it got finished
even though it was the middle of the
winter this is from William Blake Oh
rose thou art sick
the invisible worm that flies in the
night in the howling storm have found
out thy bed of crimson joy and his dark
secret love does thy life destroy this
is another story from Solzhenitsyn about
a woman's camp he's standing in another
camp watching this occur because the
women of course were put in a camp
separate from the men fire fire the
branches crackle and the night wind of
late autumn blows the flame of the
bonfire back and forth the compound is
dark I'm alone at the bonfire
and I can bring it still some more
carpenter shavings the compound that I'm
in is a privileged one so privileged
that it is almost as if I were out in
freedom this is an island of paradise
this is the Murphy no shurochka which
was a scientific Institute staffed with
prisoners in its most privileged period
no one is overseeing me calling me to a
cell chasing me away from the bonfire
and even then it is chilly in the
penetrating wind but she who has already
been standing in the wind for hours her
arms straight down her head drooping
weeping then growing numb and still and
then again she begs piteously citizen
chief please forgive me I won't do it
again
the wind carries her moan to me just as
if she were moaning next to my ear the
citizen chief at the gate how
fires up his stove and does not answer
this was the gatehouse of the camp next
to us from which workers came into our
compound to lay water pipes and repair
the old ramshackle seminary building
across from me
beyond the artfully intertwined many
stranded barbed wire barricade and two
steps away from the gatehouse beneath a
bright lantern stood the punished girl
head hanging the wind tugging at her
gray work skirt her feet growing numb
from the cold and the thin scarf over
her head it had been warm during the day
when they had been digging a ditch on
our territory and another girl slipped
down into a ravine crawled her way to
the Vladek Ino Highway and escaped the
guard had bungled and Moscow city buses
ran right along the highway when they
caught on it was too late to catch her
so they raised the alarm a mean dark
major arrived and shouted that if they
failed to catch the girl the entire camp
would be deprived of visits and parcels
for a whole month because of her escape
and the women brigadiers went into a
rage and they were all shouting one of
them in particular who kept viciously
rolling her eyes oh I hope they catch
her the I hope they take scissors
and cut clip all take off all her hair
in front of the lineup this wasn't
something she had thought up for herself
this is the way they punished women in
the gulag but the girl who was now
standing outside the gatehouse in the
cold had sighed and said instead at
least she can have a good time out and
freedom for all of us the jailer
overheard what she said and now she was
being punished everyone else had been
taken off to the camp but she had been
set outside there to stand at attention
in front of the gate house this had been
at 6:00 p.m. and now it was 11 p.m. she
tried to shift from one foot to another
but the guard stuck out his head and
shouted stand at attention horror or
else it will be worse for you and now
she was not moving only weeping forgive
me citizen chief let me into the camp I
won't do it anymore but even in the camp
no one was about to say
to her alright idiot come on in the
reason they were keeping her out there
anyway for so long was that the next day
was Sunday and she wouldn't be needed
for work such a straw a blonde naive
uneducated slip of a girl she'd been
imprisoned for some spool of thread what
a dangerous thought you expressed there
little sister they want to teach you a
lesson for the rest of your life
fire fire we fought the war and we
looked into the bonfires to see what
kind of victory it would be the wind
wafted a glowing husk from the bonfire
to that flame and you girl I promise the
whole world will read about you this is
from Milton Paradise Lost for Wentz but
from the author of all ill could spring
so deep a malice to confound the race of
mankind in one root and earth with hell
to mingle and involve done all despite
the Great Creator what are the political
implications of existential psychology
if you lie you corrupt the system if you
will I enough the system becomes so
corrupt that it turns on you and becomes
murderous so the price of freedom as far
as the existentialists are concerned and
this is buttress by the historical
knowledge that they garnered during the
20th century was that you have a moral
obligation you have a moral obligation
to speak the truth to maintain the
integrity of the state as well as
fostering your own psychological
integration we'll see you on Tuesday